I'm joined now by the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt good to talk to you this morning Mr
Hunt uh if you don't have a child on the
way or a pension pot over a million
Pounds what's in this budget for you
well good morning Jane a great deal
because uh we introduced help for people
struggling with cost of living pressures
that amount to 3 300 pounds for the
typical household over this year and
last year we've extended the energy
price guarantee at two and a half
thousand pounds for another three months
we've frozen fuel Duty which will keep
the cost of petrol down and what we are
doing is we're helping people through a
very very difficult period but we're
also tackling as you mentioned just then
the long-term issues facing the economy
which is that we have a million
vacancies up and down the country and we
want to remove the barriers that stop
people from working and the biggest area
of concern for us is the NHS where
doctors have been retiring early that's
meaning that we have these long waiting
lists seven million people on the
waiting list and so we've announced
measures that will tackle those head on
but it's persuading Consultants who are
on over a hundred thousand pounds really
the problem isn't it fundamentally the
problem that we need more nurses
well we need uh more nurses and we we
are recruiting many more nurses into the
NHS but yes um I think if you can talk
to anyone in the NHS they will say uh
doctors leaving the workforce because of
pension rules is a big problem it's
something incidentally that labor
advocated last September uh West
streeting said that we should get rid of
the cap on pensions the lifetime
allowance he seems to have changed his
mind overnight on that one he said it
was crazy and it would save lives to get
rid of that cat well he's he was right
in September when he said that the
British Medical Association program
those points to them but you say you
really are helping people but but after
13 years of a conservative government
we've got teachers doctors transport
workers all out on strike even your own
civil servants are on strike analysts
have said that by freezing income tax in
the budget yesterday you're effectively
adding 4p to income tax for around 6
million people that's from the obr
people are losing money and the obr says
it's going to get worse before it gets
better this isn't a budget for the
people
well we had to help people in the
pandemic we spent 400 billion pounds
helping businesses and families we're
spending nearly 100 billion pounds
helping families with cost of living
pressures because of the energy crisis
we have to be honest with people that
has an impact on our accounts will
always be responsible with people's
money and we want to help people through
a difficult period but we want to go on
the path to lower taxes as conservatives
one of the things that's happened in the
last year for the first time ever in
this country you can earn a thousand
pounds a month without paying a penny of
tax or national insurance so
conservatives will always bring taxes
down when we can but when people are
going through difficult periods as they
are now with these huge increases in
energy bills of course we want to help
people
but you've only got 18 months to to
bring in these tax cuts of which we've
not seen any in this budget I mean is it
enough to catch up labor before the next
election that there's you know some 20
points ahead are you not concerned that
an 18 months time the narratives of the
conservatives crashing the economy is
still going to be at the front of
everyone's mind this isn't bold enough
well well I think um if you look at the
measures I announced yesterday which are
removing the barriers for thousands
hundreds of thousands of parents who are
struggling to get back to work because
of child care
don't cut in child care costs that's
nearly 60 percent I think the one thing
people wouldn't say Jane is that it's
not bold in terms of its ambition we
want to remove the barriers that stop
people who want to from working by the
way there's a huge package in there for
long-term sick and disabled because we
think with the potential of working from
home Zoom teams the idea that because
you have a disability means you you
shouldn't be able to work or you can't
work we think that's very outdated and
we're going to get rid of the work
capability assessment and give people
support to help them get back into work
so this is I think a budget that helps
businesses fill their vacancies sorry
carry on it's just about the speed it's
just not fast enough is it I mean the
child care plans you know if you've got
a nine-month-old baby you're not going
to benefit from these because your baby
will be three or four by the time it
kicks in or if you have a three-year-old
baby it'll be five by the time it kicks
in in fact it's only people who are
thinking about getting pregnant now who
are going to benefit from this it's not
going to have kicked in by the next
election and it's going to take three
years to organize wrap around child care
for schools why on Earth does it take so
long to sort out kids clubs
well this is the biggest transformation
in child care in my lifetime Jane it's a
huge change and we're going to need
thousands more nurseries thousands more
schools offering provision they don't
currently offer thousands more child
minders we are going as fast as we can
get the supply in the market to expand
but it's the right thing to do because
we have one of the most expensive Child
Care Systems in the world and we know
that it's something that's a huge worry
for women in particular that they have
this Cliff Edge when maternity leave
ends after nine months no help until the
child turns three and that can often be
career ending so I think it's the right
thing to do for many many women to
introduce these reforms and we are
introducing them as quickly as we can
because we want to remove those barriers
to work by the way that's also very good
for business which is why yesterday's
measures were welcomed by the main
business organizations like the CBI uh
they've been saying for for some time
now that child care is causing a big
problem for businesses who are losing
staff when they really need them the
most
have also said yes it's great that
business is having investment but one
thing that you didn't mention yesterday
was public sector pay and and you you
need to invest in business but you also
need to invest invest in the public
sector why do you not think these two
things run side by side
well they do and that's why in the
Autumn statement we announced an eight
billion pound package for the NHS and
social care system a three billion pound
package for our schools those pay
negotiations are happening now I think
they seem to be making encouraging
progress we'll wait for news but we're
we want to solve them as quickly as we
can and that's why we're having those
discussions
you made it really clear that
yesterday's budget was all about getting
people back to work why do you think
fewer people came back to work in the UK
after covert than they did in in Europe
and the rest of the world and we have so
many people on long term sick why do you
think this is has the UK got a
particular problem with laziness
I don't think that at all I think people
in this country work extremely hard but
um and if you look at what's happened
over the last 13 years since we've been
in power unemployment has halved we have
two million more disabled people in work
we have a you know an employment level
at 76 percent that's fairly normal for
advanced economies but if we had the
employment levels they have in Holland
for example we would have 2.7 million
more people in work so we could fill
every vacancy nearly three times over
and that's why we recognize when we want
to boost growth to generate more tax
revenues for our NHS and our schools
that we need to remove the barriers that
stop for example young parents from
going back to work when they have
children
do we need more immigration the OVR has
pointed out that a quarter of a million
people are expected to come to the UK
this year do you think that that
fundamentally is something we need to be
focusing on
well I think the decision of the British
people in the brexit referendum was that
we want an economic model that does not
depend on unlimited low-skilled
migration and um do you think that's why
yesterday
well that's why I want to change that
and that's why yesterday I set about
systematically removing the barriers not
just young parents worried about child
care costs but job Seekers older people
long-term sick and disabled those four
groups of people where there are lots of
people who face barriers to work and we
want to take away those barriers so that
we don't have an economy that is
dependent on unlimited migration
okay one final question before I let you
go because I know you've got lots of
other interviews to do Credit Suisse How
concerned should we be about what is
happening there are you worried about
contagion in British Banks
well as you know Jane chancellors never
comment on what's happening in the
markets obviously I'm following the
situation the governor of the bank of
England is following it very closely I
think the news we've heard from the
Swiss authorities this morning is
encouraging but I won't say any more
than that
Jeremy Hunt very good he's talked to us
thanks a lot for joining us
thank you